there's an attack in progress on six in
Bell
that's my metahuman app yeah you know I
got the little ringtone on these
basically drowning people in tar
then come walking tar pit too slow
I wasn't fast enough
hey youtubers it's Charlie new flash
footage for next week so we have two big
things happening tarp it is going to
make his debut he's a big comic book
character that Geoff Johns created and
we're gonna get a bunch more zoom stuff
the other really big thing is it seems
like Harrison wells is going to be
siphoning speedforce from Barry for zoom
and it is going to cause him to not be
able to save iris like it's going to
cost him some speed that's just the way
the trailer is presenting it but that
might be false narration that might not
be the way it goes down in the episode
people from the flash family finding
themselves in moments like this is
actually a pretty common thing there
were a couple really big moments that
Wally West and Barry Allen both had the
reverse fly professors room the reverse
flash would go back to try to kill iris
West Barry had to snap his neck that led
to the big trial of the flash storyline
which they're actually gonna do on the
TV show at some point remember that
scene in the finale where Barry is
time-traveling and he sees himself in
prison the producers said that that was
a no bodge to trial of the flash but
they made it sound like they weren't
gonna get to that this season so I'm not
expecting to see Barry in prison anytime
soon it's kind of a bummer because I was
hoping that earth to Barry being in
prison would be good evidence that he's
not zoom but if they're not gonna do it
this season and they're gonna show us
who zoom is then it's all a wash Barry's
still on the list of people that zoom
could be this is actually a good picture
of the directors son from the last
episode with zoom like really up close
in the suit but the problem is is that
they could put any actor in that suit
and then put the real actor like
whenever the mask gets ripped off put
the real actor in whenever that moment
comes that's how they do scenes with
earth-1 Barry like our Barry fighting
zoom like episode six
if Barry is gonna be zoom then it'd have
to be Grant Gustin in that suit and
they'd have to fight each other so I'm
guessing most of the zoom scenes we've
seen this season or a body double it's
not the actual person that will end up
being zoom talking about who zoom could
be is its own video series because think
about it who would talk like that whose
voice would sound like that if they just
got more full speed force either zoom
started out as a normal person and his
body was twisted by the Speed Force or
it's someone in the costume that's just
doing Batman voice they're trying to
sound like Tony Todd on purpose it's not
that their voice normally sounds like
that this is what Barry's voice sounds
like when he modulates it
now this is what the reverse flashes
voice sounds like when he modulates it
very evil character still modulates his
voice this is what it sounds like
Christina McGee who are you so now you
have to think who would sound like Tony
Todd modulating his voice in real life
does zooms still sound like Tony Todd
when he's not modulating his voice just
things to think about when you're
thinking about who zoom could be
obviously it has to be someone of the
same height even if they were using a
body double it would be someone of
similar height I will just say right now
I'm really hoping that it's Joe West I
feel like that would be amazing but they
might end up going the berry route or
they might go the Jay Garrick route but
I feel like the hunter zolomon zoom
thing is a bit misleading I feel like
you shouldn't assume that hunters olam
on the earth one Jay Garrick is zoom
because zoom is supposed to be from
Earth to don't worry though you will get
a lot more scenes with zoom because of
this Harrison wells subplot him trying
to steal Barry's speed so over the next
couple weeks we'll get some more
evidence about who zoom might be but
they did say they're holding that card
really close to the vest so almost like
the end of the season so it's not gonna
be like last year it was either episode
14 or episode 15 when eobard thawne
killed Cisco the first time that's when
we officially found out who just to
explain the origin of Tarpon this is
gonna be fun I love that Cisco built
himself a metahuman app so of all the
characters the Geoff Johns created and
brought into the comics tarp it debuted
relatively early he debuted in 2001 so
tarp it is a deep cut and if you guys
watch my flash episode 11 video last
week I explained how geoff johns created
tarp it when he was a little kid and
then he became a comic book creator
brought him into the flash comic when he
had the opportunity so a character that
geoff johns created as a little kid just
like a little doodle that he created
when he was super little is now gonna be
on TV how cool is that but in the
context of the flash universe his powers
are actually really interesting he's not
like Clayface his real name is Joseph
Monteleone so what happened is he found
that he could project himself he had
this mutant ability to project his
astral form into inanimate objects in
one night he found that his form got
stuck in a vat of tar thus he became tar
pit
so it's really like his spirit infusing
tar it's not like Clayface where his
biological form estar now a lot of you
are asking well what happened to his
body if he projected his form astrally
it got stuck in tar he became tar pit so
this like walking conscious piece of tar
was walking around what happened to his
original body it fell into a coma in
iron Heights and he just forgot about it
like he just ran off and became tar pit
he was even part of the Suicide Squad
for a little while during blackest night
now moving into the TV universe the TV
show tends to change the comic book
characters like the way they got their
powers a little bit just because of the
particle accelerator explosion but we
know there are pre-existing metahumans
in the world I'm guessing the TV show is
gonna use the classic explainer that he
has the metahuman gene it was activated
by the Dark Matter explosion but we'll
see how they end up doing it I'm totally
cool with the flash TV show making minor
changes to the way characters get their
powers like the killer frost earth to
thing that they have going on they've
completely earned my loyalty it's
totally cool
DC Comics changes the comics more often
than the TV show changes things if you
guys didn't know Ethan Van Sciver just
re-signed with DC Comics geoff johns
dropped this big rebirth teaser so i'm
guessing they're gonna be teaming up for
some big event series i don't know when
it's gonna start though so if you're
really into the comics geoff johns ethan
fancy for like the people that did
blackest night that did flash rebirth
that did emerald art they're probably
going to be working together again on a
big big project has promised
congratulations to the most recent
reverse flash ring giveaway winner Jade
Fox please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I get your
contact details what's gonna happen is
is I'll start a new round whenever I
post my flash video next week there is
gonna be a Batman V Superman video this
weekend there's some new Wonder Woman
footage there's a whole bunch of stuff
to talk about there's like a billion DC
videos and there's supposed to be some
big DC stuff happening around the
Superbowl so I'm not sure if they're
gonna drop a new trailer but they're
gonna be doing something because Fox and
Marvel are spending millions of dollars
promoting movies I think it's gonna be a
lot of Captain America a lot of Deadpool
and a lot of x-men apocalypse but I
don't know exactly which trailer is
gonna be airing yet but be sure to
subscribe to get everything
whatever ends up happening I will
totally do videos for everything it's
gonna be awesome
really big weekend coming I have a
couple more videos that I'm working on
I'll try get out as fast as possible why
you guys wait for that you can click
here for my legends of tomorrow video
from last night and you can click here
for all my deadpool videos i just posted
a new one bunch of people getting kicked
in the nuts it's great thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight